welcome back how President Trump can
honor Kate Steinle and shame San
Francisco that's the topic of tonight's
bonus angle president Trump has an
enormous amount of discretion as chief
executive and one of his many unilateral
powers seems small but it actually can
be used for something big as in sending
a message to the cities and states
across America who refused to help the
federal government enforce immigration
law now by now you've heard of the
travesty of a jury verdict in that Kate
Steinle murder case in which the accused
killer five times deported Jose in Eze
Garcia Zarate was convicted only on a
minor gun possession charge
meaning the guy's gonna likely be
released soon due to time served
California of course is the state that
says me and many of those to all who
cross its borders so it's full on
sanctuary status thus is in the case of
mr. Serrat a San Francisco did not honor
the feds request for an immigration
detainer hold and so he was released
shameful now one of his defense
attorneys Francisco you got a had the
utter gall to say this after his client
received that slap on the wrist this
case was used as a means to foment hate
to foment division to foment
a program of mass deportation it was
used to catapult a presidency along that
philosophy of hate of others and I
believe today is a vindication for the
rights of immigrants notice how he
conflates immigrants with illegal
immigrants that's the old trick that's
what they always pull it so transparent
so you ask what can we as Americans do
now you would think that the election of
Donald Trump last year would have been a
wake-up call but instead some of these
cities are actually doubling down in
favor of open borders endless benefits
and more protections for illegals now
certainly of course defunding sanctuary
cities is an absolute must and the house
has already passed legislation to do
just that so the Senate now needs to act
really quickly get it done but here's
another idea a simple google search of
federal parks in San Francisco lists
several including the San Francisco
maritime National Historical Park now
that's not a particularly interesting
name is it for a park that was
established just in 1988 so I have an
idea
check it out suppose this week President
Trump issues a presidential proclamation
renaming that Park Kate Steinle spark
now would Nancy Pelosi then file suit to
enjoin President Trump from having new
signs posted
well how about Governor Jerry Brown
would he oppose it or that left-wing or
San Francisco Mayor Ed Lee the sign
bearing the name of MS Steinle just
think about it it would stand as a stark
reminder that all lives matter even if
some politicians in court seem to care
more about the lives of illegal aliens
than they do the lives of lawful
citizens and legal immigrants to the
United States and that's the bonus angle